Salut les Mentalos,
Aujourd'hui je vous explique une astuce psychologique pour bluffer quelqu'un
C'est un forçage de carte psychologique
Alors, qu'on soit bien d'accord,
Mon but dans cette vidéo, c'est pas de vous bluffer vous parce que vous connaissez déjà le principe
Vous connaissez mon objectif : forcer quelque chose psychologiquement
Donc ça ne marchera pas sur vous
Puisque vous savez
Voilà, comme ça je l'ai dit
Et je serai sûr de pas avoir de commentaire "Ah ça n'a pas marché sur moi"
Quoiqu'en disant ça je vais avoir des commentaires comme ça
C'est compliqué...
Mon but c'est bien de vous apprendre quelque chose de bluffant que vous allez pouvoir reproduire et même améliorer à votre sauce à vous
Je vais vous le présenter comme vous devriez le présenter à un spectateur ou à quelqu'un
Alors forcément vous pouvez le faire en même temps, mais rappellez vous de ce que je vous ai dit il y a quelques secondes déjà
Vous allez devoir choisir une de ces 5 cartes, mais ne vous laissez pas influencer par exemple vous pourrez vous dire que j'ai mis l'as au milieu pour que vous le preniez
Ou que le 6 est d'une couleur différente, et que c'est pour vous induire à le choisir
Vous choisissez la carte que vous voulez, librement, complètement librement, maintenant allez-y
Avant de vous révéler la carte que vous auriez dû choisir ou que votre spectateur du moins devrait choisir
Je vais vous dire 2 mots quand même sur ce forçage, il n'est pas de moi mais de "Banachek" qui c'est inspiré à l'époque des travaux de Dai Vernon
Pour créer ce forçage là, psychologique,
Qui est très intéressant et surtout très efficace
Je vais vous mettre un lien dans le descriptif
Qui vous renvoie vers tous les livres qu'a publié Banachek
C'est une mine d'or, une ressource
Surtout sur les forçages psychologiques
Je vous incite vraiment à vous procurer ou à vous faire prêter ces livres-là
Qui sont extrêmement intéressants.
En temps normal le spectateur choisit le 4 de coeur
Après avoir hésité sur le 9 de carreau.
Tout d'abord toutes les cartes que vous allez citer
Il va pas les choisir
Parce que vous mettez en avant leurs différences
Et vous les avez citées, donc l'As, ça l'élimine complètement
Et la carte noire ça l'élimine complètement aussi
Dans la plupart des forçages, on remarque que les extrêmes ne sont jamais choisis
Qui plus est pour le roi qui est une carte forte, une valeur, il sort également du lot
Donc on a pas envie de le prendre
D'où cette hésitation sur le 9 de carreau
Mais encore une fois c'est un extrême
Donc on a envie de cacher son choix
Et il va se porter sur la carte d'à côté : le 4
Qui n'est pas très visible
Qui a l'air, en fait, anodin
Il est tellement anodin que c'est lui le plus différent des autres
Alors, au-delà de cette application très précise de Banachek
J'aimerais vous ouvrir l'esprit sur tout ce que vous pouvez faire avec ça
Vous pouvez l'adapter à plus de cartes, à moins de cartes, à des objets également
Pourquoi pas à des mots
A toutes sortes de choses en réalité
Moi je me suis servi de cette méthode et d'autres méthodes
Pour créer la vidéo que je vais mettre ici et puis en lien sur les croix
Ça fait partie des techniques que j'ai employées pour faire cette vidéo là.
Je vous en dit pas plus si jamais vous ne l'avez pas vue
Si vous avez d'autres idées d'applications ou d'autres idées de forçage psychologique de cartes
On peut en parler dans les commentaires
Vraiment ça fait plaisir
Je vous lis, n'oubliez jamais ça. Je vous lis tous !
Amusez-vous bien, n'oubliez pas de laisser un pouce en l'air avant de partir
Et de vous abonner à la chaîne puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour
Pendant toute une année depuis le 1er janvier au 31 décembre
Donc rendez-vous demain à 17h, ciao !
Je joue mon spectacle en entier le 23 septembre
A la Garenne-Colombes, c'est la date la plus proche de Paris
Si jamais vous voulez venir sinon il y a toutes les dates de tournée
Sur mon site...